nope okay
there we go
okay so let's see here the price scalper
is an indicator that takes advantage of
small price movements by combining
aspects of both price action and Order
flow trading and this indicator is
designed to help Traders make a better
decision by providing you know more
information about the markets right
because at the end of the day you know
we're Traders right we got a lot going
on in our plates and we do rely on
indicators to help us you know find
trades there's so many different ways to
trade the market
so
uh where am I here
order flow and
price action right they're both
different ways to look at the market you
know people will say uh you know
everything about price everything about
the market is reflected in price whereas
order flow really you're paying
attention to what's happening
um the way the Market's reacting to
price and how it's trading so they sort
of go hand in hand and you know for a
long time I've I've Been Working On
Tools to sort of incorporate some price
action activities into order flow
analysis and
you know while there's not one single
tool that said oh you could buy this
it's going to change your life you could
just go out and you know take a second
mortgage on your house
um start trading no it's not like that
you know trading is still a decision
based um form of analysis and you know
you still want to be able to make some
trading decisions you know we I could
have made it the price go up or more
black boxy and add in all sorts of
filters and stuff like that so that
you wouldn't have to do any of that
analysis but you know people use
different forms of analysis when they
approach the markets right so if you're
looking you know some people don't use
at HMA a whole moving average you know
maybe they want to use a WMA to filter
out trade so you
you have that ability okay now I like to
use order flow together with the price
scalper I'm always looking for reasons
to take trades based on the order flow
and when I have things that are backed
up by
um price action
with a little bit of order flow put in
to me that's those are great trading
opportunities and you can see here on
this chart right we have a bullish
Prominent Point of control let me get
something here so you can see it a
little bit better my laser pointer right
we've got a bullish point of control so
if you use order flow right if you use
the order flows Trader software and
you're using tool price scalper right
you just wait for the bullish order flow
be confirmed with the price scalper I
want to take you sort of through it in
in a second I'm just going through a
couple of examples here you can also use
price scalper on a normal bar chart now
there's different ways you could display
price scalper right one
I always like to have it you know on the
chart itself
or you could also add it at the bottom
right so these little ticks up mean it
was bullish the red ticks down are
bearish signals so bullish signal bear
signal but you don't have to have this
part here on your chart you can just
look like a normal bar chart without
that but if you're looking at something
like a footprint chart you know you got
a lot of information just having that
little extra line on the bottom
removes all doubt you know because
sometimes you know the little triangle
it may print there you may miss it
sometimes when you have something big
like this on the bottom it's just right
there right in your face that
you know you just can't miss it okay
Lord knows I've I've missed signals
sometimes just because I'm I'm looking
at the chart and I just missed that that
little thing there simple really school
boy error but sometimes that stuff
happens
um
this was the other day on e-minis it was
Monday
right right at the cash open bullet
signal a couple bare signals that didn't
work out
a bullet signal again didn't really work
out and you got a nice bullish signal
here in here okay and having this on the
bottom having this plot on the bottom
again is just an extra way to tell you
hey you know what I've got a bullish
signal I've got a bear signal because
when you're looking at multiple markets
you got a big screen you know nowadays
we've all got these big screens or we've
got these very wide screens you've got
different charts open having that extra
thing on the bottom is
you know helps you helps you as a Trader
find see those trades
now
to install price scalper right it's very
very simple all you got to do is you
just download it to your PC you don't
unzip the file you know some computers
nowadays they got all these
um
what do you want to call it uh
these filters if you will you know you
don't download things that are harmful
to your computer and this is a ZIP file
that you're downloading so it'll say you
know do you really want to download this
so sometimes you got to like accept it
um you know at the bottom of your screen
and then you don't unzip it you just
import that whole zip file into
ninjatrader8 and that's it okay then as
far as the licensing goes for those of
you that already have it I made a simple
mistake in this in the user guide when
your license key is your family name
with the and simple there so it'd be
like Jones then the and symbol and make
sure you click enable
okay and then click apply and then it'll
work now the swing filter this is really
the only setting you got to worry about
okay I mean there's offset like how far
above or below the bar you want the to
appear if you want to use the sound
um
the sound feature right you sometimes
you're gonna hear my computer during
this presentation uh beep and that's the
sound filter buy or sell colors again
you can adjust that now the swing filter
is really the only setting that you're
going to be making adjustments on a
market by market basis for slower moving
markets like bonds ZB Ultra bonds 10
years I suggest the lowest setting which
is one
for normal movie markets like currencies
es I'd suggest a setting of five or ten
for the fastest most volatile markets
like Dax NQ mnq I saw a question Milton
um NQ again this is based off of a one
minute chart so
what I use for a one minute chart is
sort of like starting point that I would
use in every Market okay because again
some people don't use time based charts
they use tick based charts they use
volume based charts
but this is my starting points all right
so one on slow moving markets five to
ten yeah again and I can say seven this
is five or ten right you you could
adjust it you know what you're
comfortable with and how many signals
you you know if you start going up in
terms of
um strength you know a higher number
stronger it's going to give you less
signals right that's why on volatile
markets because the markets are just too
volatile there's a lot of price
Discovery going on you're going to set
the settings at
um you know a higher number just because
bars cover more real estate so to speak
um you know going up and down
now I had explained really briefly on
the bottom panel right which is this
part here okay
if you want to see that you can adjust
it in the settings under
um the visuals here so you gotta select
new panel right because right now when
it says same as input series it's just
showing it as
nothing right and it's transparent the
colors so it's not plotting anything so
you'll have to change the plotting from
transparent to Blue
and
for the buys and for cells from a
transparent to red right it shows as
transparent transparent now it's blue
for buys Red for cells in a new panel
you don't want it to appear on the same
panel
um you wouldn't be able to read anything
on
on your chart
so by adding those to the bottom of your
chart it just makes it a little bit
easier to see especially if you're using
a footprint chart all right I just find
it a lot easier to see personally and
one thing to realize again depending on
which footprint software you're using if
you're using mine or using you know
volumetric charts from the paid version
of ninjatrader or any other third party
you know depending on how they draw the
candles
you may have to make an adjustment okay
and
I'll show you what I mean right if I
just put on the
normal settings
right oftentimes the bar width of the
Candlestick chart you may not realize
this in your footprint
but this bar width under the data Series
right you can adjust this if it's set
very wide it'll draw a wide candles on
price scalper so all you have to do is
you just adjust it to a smaller number
two right so you can see in here it's
just right there now you see it's dark
red because I have the settings
set to dark red
under
here right the cell color is dark red
the buys are blue that's why the candle
is appearing dark red right dark red and
blue for bullish ones I like to have the
candles colored that way I can you know
get a better visual
but really what you got to do is you
gotta just adjust the bar width down to
two otherwise it's going to look very
wide like this and you're not gonna be
able to see your footprint potentially
so just bear that in mind okay now
I'm going to take a look at something
really quick
I'm just going to pull up a chart here
um okay so this is the e-minis okay so I
don't have the
part on the bottom showing up let me get
a uh
crosshairs here okay now this is set at
one okay I can see it's set at one here
what you have to do right again to
change the setting you just open up the
indicator
the swing filter right here again you
know you can set it to five click apply
you can set it to 10 click apply that's
really the only one you really need to
adjust if you want to put the plotting
on the bottom right you just go to
visuals same as input series change that
to new panel then you're going to want
to change the colors okay because
transparent obviously you're not going
to be able to see so again you know
where's blue in here
change it to blue and red okay
so you see right there okay so again
you'll also see what it's set at what
your settings are right there it's
dropped it from up here to down here on
this panel now one of the ways that
when we were creating this indicator you
know someone asked me the programmer
asked me you know do you want to put
that filter in there for
um a trend filter
like do you want to take trades when the
market is going up or when the market is
going down
HMA is a hall moving average which is a
nice filter but it what it does is at
least make this darker here
um golden rods kind of hot let's make it
black and I'll make the line uh
a bit heavier to see and what the trend
filter is going to do
is as this Market is going down right
you're going to be trading on the short
side if it's going up right so you're
not going to take this trade you're not
going to take this trade
um you're going to be just taking shorts
as the markets go down or the Market's
going up taking Longs now
if you're going to use a trend filter
okay I wouldn't use the settings that I
just talked about earlier I would just
keep it at the very lowest one of one
okay and in a minute right I'm going to
talk about
markers and show you how you can set it
in so you'd just be taking trades when
the market is trending down now this is
yeah I just threw this up as HMA uh 14
you could use you know you don't have to
use HMA you could use whatever you want
I know some people love using a nine EMA
all right it's up to you
where's e here we are uh
foreign
color make it uh what's a little bit
easier to see make it blue
okay you know some people like to use a
nine period EMA you know for whatever
doesn't matter
um you know depending on how fast a
Trader you are or or what it's up to you
to choose whichever one you want to use
but you can filter this in a tool
like markers okay so you could automate
that and that's sort of the the next
portion that I want to talk about or you
know the later portion but again you
always want to be trading in the
direction of the trend right you don't
want to just be following
um
price alone by itself right you want to
be following the order flow together
with price action right so imagine right
you can take out a lot of these losing
trades just by following the trend right
here's a nice move you know to see this
Market is trending down on both averages
you only need one you don't need to have
both on here you get a nice move down
right just as during the day and again
this is e-minis if you're looking at
um you know say you know Ultra bonds is
a nice Market you know someone asked me
the other day what to recommend for
Ultra bonds I recommend just the setting
of one right you don't really even need
to have
any
Trend filter I mean look at this Ultra
bonds there's only how many signals
today there's one here I mean this is a
tremendous move 140 all the way up to
you know almost 142.
you know this one's coming in 139.30
you know here's some chop back and forth
but again you know this move down
this one would have stopped you out and
this next bar stopped you out but you
can see right nice moves you could have
right on slower moving markets this is a
thing you know everyone loves to trade
Equity indices you know NASDAQ Minis
because it sounds sexy you know no one
wants to trade greens or you know even
bond trading does sound a bit sexy but
um these other markets
follow order flow and price action
really well the problem with markets
like
um s PS
mnq NQ is
there's a lot of other money involved in
there people that are trading you know
Ultra bonds
even Ultra tens
are people that
need to trade it right for whatever
reason
so in my opinion it's something that
follows supply and demand much better
than these other markets is have a lot
of hot money in it right money that's
just out there
um you know people are playing around
with I mean people don't
view these other markets you know this
the same way there's
tenure uh this is the ultra 10 years you
know from this morning you got a nice
move here now we'll move up here move
down a little back and forth in here
back and forth
we'll move up today was actually a bit
more active in the ultra 10 years but
you've seen it just Trends beautifully
right and if you're a Trader right you
want to trade the markets that are just
giving you those the nice trades day in
and day out right 10 years Ultra bonds
Ultra 10 years rather the TN the ultra
bonds you know are great contracts for
Traders to trade I mean look at this
this is two in the morning nice move up
nice move back down
right
so
before I get into markers let me just
take a look at a couple of
[Music]
questions here
um
someone had asked about Forex I'll say I
don't follow the Forex markets I follow
the Forex Futures okay
uh uh will it work with Forex again
you're better off just trading the
Futures Market rather than the
Forex itself
um because the data is just it's
centralized right with Forex data comes
from everywhere right it comes from
different banks so depending on who your
Forex broker is and who they're white
labeling their trading platform from is
that's where you're getting your quotes
from so like Futures it comes from the
exchange the centralized comes from one
spot then it goes to the data providers
whereas
if you're trading Forex at different
Brokers you know it's coming from all
the different Brokers you're going to
different data providers it's just very
disjointed it's a bit like it's a bit
like well crypto is like that only 100
times
that level
um Keith asked how many ticks in your
opinion is considered a scalp
okay well
the scalp is basically the shortest
amount you could hold a trade
right I mean ideally you know every
trade is going to start out
as a scalp right because you don't know
if it's going to go or not
it can
move start a nice move
or it can just Peter out you know I mean
in the old days on the floor there's
these the groups you know there's the
scalpers they would just hold the trade
three four seconds right they're buying
the bid they're selling the offer if
they someone hit them okay they're long
offer it out
five seconds
if they can't get rid of it they just
scratch it so
for me
I'm looking to hold a trade
ideally as long as it can go
in my favor but if it's not going in my
favor I'll try and cut it as soon as I
can right that's
that's part of trading right it's not
just let the trade go to your
um
take profit or to your stop right you
got to be adjusting it you got to adjust
your stop I mean like
yesterday when I was trading it's like
the markets were selling off and it's
like
I would just move my stop down into the
money so sometimes you know
it would bounce up and I'd get stopped
out at a profit of just two points as
opposed to getting out you know at my
take profit because I moved my stop down
right if I kept my stop way up there
yeah I would have gone to my take profit
I mean it really everyone's got a
different style of trading so it's
really hard to say you know what's
considered a scalp is basically one tick
but
think of it don't think of it as just
scalping out one tick
you know I train on a very short time
frame you know 30 second charts I don't
go beyond five minutes I don't I do look
at them but um you know try and keep it
your viewpoint
as um
ideally as short as possible to start
out but if after you're in the trade if
things are conducive to you staying in
that trade longer stay in it the deep
blue and deep red candles represent the
sort of this the signal taking place in
the market where things are manifesting
of either a Buy Signal or a sell signal
the up or down arrow or triangle is the
actual trade signal so it won't come in
on the actual bar right you can see here
it won't signal here
it's waiting for the next bar
for it to Signal this is just sort of
giving you a heads up that's why
sometimes you see bars like this
where things are manifesting right it
looks potentially bearish it's deep red
that it's going to sell off but then it
just doesn't
confirm it it's just really more of a
visual to sort of say hey you know what
things are looking like a potential
short here
but that's not the actual signal right
the signal would be the up or down
triangle the up triangle here the down
triangle here and again that coincides
with what you're seeing on the bottom
right the here's the down triangle right
it coincides with the down tick here the
up triangle here
all right coincides with this so you
don't see this happening on this bar
this is just telling you hey get ready
things are shaping up for potential buy
or potential cell
um Derek no unfortunately you can't make
the triangles um larger
yeah Marty asked does the signal plot at
the end of the bar yes it does
um
Philip asks
can a triangle symbol be changed to any
other
bar
type like a large Dot
oh you want dots up here
um
I don't think so
pretty sure not because it's it's just
something you know I gave them I said
draw a triangle if I told them to draw a
taxi would have drawn a DOT on it but
it's not adjustable in that sense
if you change any of these plots down
here right that's going to change what
you're seeing down at the bottom here
okay
like this is a solid line right that's
why you see the solid line down
um
ads and you touch on the market
structure logic you have built in I am
asking us into the water flow indicator
to make this one this Market structure
um
well I didn't say that markets did I say
it had Market structure and I said price
action
um in the market structure of stratum
the other indicators got uh
Market structure built into it this is
more on price action and Order flow so
it's again it's sort of a combination of
bullish or bearish order flow together
with bullish or bearish Price action
foreign
asks a couple questions here how is this
different
it talks about crude oil
um
how different this indicator compare
compared to Delta scalper and turns
um well it's
much different
um let me see here I'll
put them both on because again you don't
need to use tick replay on this I mean
you can have degree play on and it'll
still work but I know
turns whoops I know turns and um
Delta scalper need it so I'll turn on
pick replay and
Delta scalper I'll just leave it at
basic I'll change just as you're just
really quick I didn't run it side by
side but they look at completely
different things so
let's see here
what's this price scalper
foreign
so there was one bearish signal here
they both appeared on
um
bearish signal came a little bit
different but again price copper looks
at completely different things than
the uh what you call it
Delta scalper so for example right you
can see this price scalper I've got it
turned on basically at its very lowest
setting for
Delta scalper if I were to
sort of put it at go to the default
settings you're going to see less
signals
it's calculating
so this is sort of the setting that I
recommend for most markets to start with
so Delta scalper
you know those
potential signal here right you see the
Zone being drawn out but no actual
signal there
so you can see you know it's just
looking at different things
here is one where they both kicked off
at the same time you know there's a
small move about
six seven ticks
um
again here's one there's a bias of both
of them kicking off right here
again they look at they look at very
different things so I'm not surprised to
sort of see that I'm not really giving
um the same signals uh let's see
get asked about turns
turns
set that at three
I don't even know how it turns is gonna
whoops sorry
thought I had my phone on mute there
um okay so here's turns
in the ultra bonds I'm sorry 10 Ultra
tens it was a buy sell signal here
buying a sell signal here
that wasn't an actual signal there on
the currents but you see they're just
they're coming in they're some I think
it's just more of coincidence that
they're appearing at the same area
here's one that's
appearing at the same time
um
I don't think it's something that you
gotta get
you can really you know here's one that
appeared the same
on the bearish side here's a bullish one
again you know it's one of those things
where
you know when you're dealing with the
order flow and the order flow indicator
it's looking at for something very
unique specific in the order flow right
so sometimes you're adding different
order flow indicators yeah I mean a bar
could have many things happening in the
order flow you know it could be a
bullish problem control you could have
imbalances you could have something
going on in the Delta
um you could have
you know minus development going on so
yeah a bar could exhibit three or four
different things
um
just like using different indicators can
appear
um three or four different things you
know if I put enough indicators up on
here I'm sure there'll be some instances
where
where it appears like you know I have
four things going on that must be
something
stronger you know I I don't like to
think that way I just like to think yeah
you know at this what I'm seeing in the
market makes uh perfect sense crude oil
let's take a look here at crude oil now
I I wouldn't use a setting of one and
one
or a setting of one on the price
scalper
unless I was using
um you know some sort of filter okay I
mean yeah here's a nice bearish signal
here one is going to give you a lot of
signals on a market like crude it's a
little bit volatile
um
you'd probably want to use something you
know
a little bit higher you know
wear my hair
right let's pull it in here
and go back where are we here so
this is short here is along here short
you know short down up
down so where we are right now in this
market you know there's a rally up here
a little push down but just went
sideways
so you know I'd use 10. you know crude
oil sort of falls under like the euro
currency and um
e-minis
okay
uh
James Wilkins James I want to make a
note you can
be asking about the sequencing and
and price action price scalper
swap just
yeah just shoot me an email and I'll
reply to it today okay James
um Richard no it's not available for
train station
the whole speech what's going on in es
right now
uh Jay Powell
um wow
ES
3670 yeah I saw what was it Goldman
Sachs revised their
mini call or s p call rather from I
think was 40
4 500 by year end to 3600 we're not that
far off right now
um so again I got this it's taking a
little bit longer because I have tick
replay enabled on this chart but you
don't need to use tick replay
um
you know there's a short here along here
that just failed
it's
this is a setting of 10 you know there
was a short up here this is what 8 30
where's 8 30. this is 8 30.
some volatility coming on a long air
short here a long back up
it's a little long a short
um
you know overnight had some nice a nice
move overnight I remember waking up this
morning
and looking at the market and thinking
oh we're still above 37 then it like I
got my kids ready for school next thing
I knew I was like
send them off to school it's like 37 20.
like I thought we were just trading
37.40
um but you know there's a short signal
here
overnight
overnights
training is possible overnight people
always wonder you know hey can I can I
trade overnight you know there's enough
volume yeah there is in the e-minis
there is most contracts actually are
okay to trade overnight but definitely
the e-mini Z minis trade more overnight
than some contracts trade during the day
what you're seeing in here right nice
move up nice move down
um going on right there
um
crude I showed you crude
roll I'm fine
and then the canvas tool be used to
trade unfinished auctions
oh I don't know how you're trading on
finish auctions
um
I don't know if I got a
all right let me add a footprint on here
really quick
um
I don't have a footprint chart here let
me just turn off some of this stuff so
it's a little easier to read here uh
you can see let's turn off some bunch of
this stuff here
I should actually Loop sequencing on
because you know one of the ways that I
like to use it is
combining it with something
in the order flow okay whether it's
um
you know
a stacked imbalance or
a Prominent Point of control I love prom
component controls with this indicator
because you know product point of
control indicates stopping volume
in the markets okay and when you have
you know heavy volume
you know sort of present there and
you're seeing something happening in the
price action then
you know it's going to give you a good
trade right and because that's what you
want right you want to have you say yeah
I know what's happening in the market
based off the order flow I see
nice stopping volume there I see Traders
stepping up to this level now
I'm seeing the price action
you know confirming it basically telling
me yeah you know what what you're
sorry about this turn this phone off
um
okay hold on while this chart comes up
here it's just taking a second
click ok but you know anytime you're
looking at anything price related when
you can combine it with order flow I
think it's going to give you a good
um
a good opportunity so while that chart's
coming up we'll take the question here
so you enter when the bar closed on the
bar where the triangle shows up yeah
Ricardo
is this much different from other
Bots you have sold in the password
well this is not a Bots okay this is an
indicator an indicator goes to a certain
things it's looking for in the order
flow to tell you what you're seeing is
bullish what you're seeing is bearish
all right so
when you're seeing bullish something
bullish in the order flow then it's
telling you hey you know what
that's the opportunity this doesn't auto
trade for you okay
when does it work better with imbalances
and other stuff in order flow okay so
let's uh
put it on here so this is a footprint
chart
this is my footprint
um peas for a price
scalper here
okay I'm gonna turn that on so just yeah
it won't tell us with that and Ampersand
there and
okay just so it's a little easier to see
I'm going to put it also on the bottom
up
blue
red
but
yeah if if you
have certain things that you look for in
the order flow okay so if you're not
using order flows Trader all right if
you're using just
a simple order flow footprint chart
right and there's certain things I'm
probably sure you're looking for in the
order flow for example
um
a stack buying imbalance or stack
selling imbalance look for
the price scalper to come in it may not
come in on the bar but you know if it's
coming down the bar afterwards to me
that's that's a legitimate sign
um
Carlo no I don't have
that for you over the next five bars you
know following up and down signal
I don't have that information for you
Maurice are these signals you're seeing
in the order flow if
they are can I see it on an order flow
chart with ratios well
this Maurice ratios is one thing in the
order flow okay it's looking at you know
the ratios that you see on the order
flows Trader right that looks at the
order flow in the bar the price scalper
doesn't look at that information so no
to answer your question
um
the overflows ratio has nothing to do
with the price scalper indicator all
right so what you're looking for is
something different so for example here
we go okay
let's just make this chart a little bit
easier to read
okay so there's a Buy Signal here at the
this is the low the new low of the day
why you just made a new low 60 what is
that 68 and a half just pretty recently
this is not a real-time chart this is a
delayed chart because this is my testing
PC
um
so you got Divergence here right you got
a new low
with positive Delta right then the next
bar okay you're getting the
actually in this bar the
information was saying you know that's
why this bar is colored blue here it
might be a little bit hard to see saying
hey you know what heads up there's a
potential signal here then you get your
confirmation in the bar afterwards
um let's see here
let's go back yesterday because I know
yesterday
with Prominent Point of controls
or other things in the order flow where
is it here
this was a
this is sequencing here okay so again if
you're using
the order flows Trader you're seeing a
lot of stuff right you're seeing the
sequencing here that's this information
and then price scalper kicking off here
moving up right really the only signals
you're going to take are these up or
down
bumps right this is a bullish One the
red one would be down now this is why I
say put on plot it on the bottom because
otherwise you'd have to offset this
triangle here right as I have set at one
that's why it's being overwritten if I
can set it two three four five then it
would appear down here
um
but you don't need to do that
if you have this on here
okay the uh
where's my chart
you know in this signal here it's
nothing really interesting in the order
flow oh
do I have
I don't report it controls even turned
on here okay I don't even have it turned
on
yeah I got it turned down there
three three okay but let's just make it
simple
okay
Uh Kevin any recommendations on trading
bonds yeah
I gave that earlier um set out one could
only trading AES and mes
um I'd start with ten Dow Jones I'd go
with uh 25
we'll take a look at Dao after this
well
Echo does this provide much Advantage
compared to thoroughly learning to use a
footprint chart
I don't say Advantage you know it's a
complement to the footprint chart I
don't think it should replace a
footprint chart I always still use a
footprint chart
you know because you still want to see
you know how a market can turn very
quick
you know and that's what the value of
footprint chart is it's going to give
you that information that the market is
is changing really quick you know that's
real-time information if you're just
looking at a
bar chart you don't pick that up right
you don't get the intensity of the
buying or selling
um
tick replay is not required it's only
required if you're using
another indicator with it that requires
tick replay it'll work with both stick
replay on or off
um Kevin
yeah I'd start with one in any of the
bond complex you know whether it's Ultra
bonds
ZB the 30-year bonds
um 10 years five years
Carlo
yeah to confirm it's the bar afterwards
so for example okay
here we go so here's my Prominent Point
of control here's my signal
right so I know already that it's
forming in here that this bar is formed
blue just as I know that there's a
potential bearish signal forming here
but it's not confirmed in the next bar
so this is the bar that's going to
confirm it and you know so you get long
here boom you know 86 and a quarter it
you know going all the way up into the
mid 90s here right I mean didn't go
eventually higher but this is one of
those trades where you know just you get
quick six points out of the market there
um
you know again here's your bullish
product control here's your boiler
signal all right so anything order flow
related whether it's a problem I put a
control whether it's a stacked imbalance
these are things that I'm always looking
for
um because we know that not everything
in the order flows even though it's
bullish it can change on you really
quick right and what was bullish all of
a sudden becomes bearish and
um
you know when you add another piece to
the
you know another spice to the recipe so
to speak it just makes things taste
better
uh
what is this
it's going I'm just going through some
questions here real quick
Pascal
okay Pascal
um
I'm just copying your email because your
message there I see your message Pascal
um
I'll take care of it but yeah
um just I'll take care of it this
afternoon
not your second license
um what order flow signal does it use
well I can't tell you that
um one other indicator that you created
would work well with it
honestly I've got a bunch of other
indicators I haven't run through all of
them at it
but things like sequencing
um Tails depending on the markets
obviously Delta scalper you saw earlier
it's just one of those things you know
the some of these tools that we have
right designed
let me see here let's pull up the list
um okay so for example like I mean
people see a lot of indicators here but
trust me some of these are just
testing things some of these are just
the ones that would probably work with
it the things like sequencing which are
basically parts of the order flow we
just had to break it out into a smaller
a separate indicator
um you know Market exhaustion probably
work well with it things like
um
sequencing entails
tension probably work well
PLC Trader but PLC Trader is already
built into the footprint
anything that reads order flow should
work well
renko Bart Heinz I don't use uh wrinkles
Albert yeah I showed you the e-minis
earlier
this evening is now
again it's coming off the low of the day
here with the um Divergence obviously
that's that stacked buying and balance
taking place in here got multiple
imbalances as well
um you know David Mark can go up yeah
kind of
was in a big move
but some you know Mark's been selling
off all day or
100 points lower than where we were
overnight
um Dave thanks Nord Dave
the other Dave are you going to show us
how to set up yep in a second
um
for markers do we need to buy the
markers Plus
well
yeah I'm not sure about that Wally
um I think you get by with plus but uh
I don't know I'll check with Pablo
um on that
yeah every once in a while Pablo has
like a special
um you know we just did Pablo and I did
a
I did a training about a couple weeks
ago and he had a special price so we did
it just after Labor Day
um he's always got sales so you can
always wait till he puts it on sale
sometimes it's you know 20 off with you
know save you some money
yeah um Steve
do you look for failure on a signal
yeah I mean for a stop
so like this is the
signal bar this is the trigger bar stop
at a
is definitely below once if it comes
into the low of the signal bar not the
trigger bar
if it's a long you know I'd be getting
out right I don't need it to sell off 20
points 20 ticks rather if you know if
we're starting trading below the
um signal bar that's where I'd be
looking to get out Derek yeah if you're
going to use a filter on everything
start at one
um
well again Albert
regarding uni renko or wrinkles I don't
um
I don't use renko or uni renko
um charts at all so
I know uni wrinkle is one there's so
many different uni rental charts out
there you know every vendor's got their
their own uni rental chart
uh do the indicators plot in real time
on bar close
yeah I mean
they plot in real time and once they
plot they won't uh they're not supposed
to change anymore
um
James asks is someone a ninja Trader
that can help set up order flow on my
chart well if you want the ninja Trader
order flow
package you have to buy their
license right which I don't know what
it's at now it's like 1200 bucks or
something like that every once in a
while I think on Black Friday or on
Christmas they put it on sale for 999
um
but then you know it's just an indicator
that will show up in your indicator
settings
so for example like this is
not my trading PC this is this is just a
free version of ninjatrader but it has
it down in here
um
was it if it was called it's called
volumetric charts or something uh V oh
you know sorry
um when you if you have the paid version
of ninjatrader when you open it up
there's gonna be a choice in here yeah
volume metric right
you just choose that that's how you
would set up on the paid version of
ninjatrader under the data series when
you open up a chart
um Maurice hey Keith sure you're welcome
um
Maurice asks
at what point we'll be able to see
Bloodhound see this you know Deltas Max
deltas
um we do have a new version of order
flows Trader coming out that makes a lot
of this stuff
um readable won't make the max Delta Min
Delta readable but it'll make a lot of
the other things in the order flow what
you're seeing in the footprint it'll
make it readable stacked imbalances
um
slingshots
things like that primary point of
controls it'll make that readable by
things like markers Etc
um you know this is sequencing here
which provides nice levels
for reading but again that's
soon soon
uh Charles Sasser
all right Charles I'm gonna copy this
I'm gonna take a look through my records
see what you got before
um
and get it out to you does it repaint no
it doesn't
aren't range charts better with overflow
why time based well problem with range
based charts
um are they better for overflow honestly
on volatile markets no you're gonna get
into trades very late on if you're using
range base let's put this at nine or
sorry at eight right I used to use
range-based charts
years ago right 2013 2014 2015 2016.
markets were a lot slower than they are
now there will be some days where you'd
have
you know a 15 Point range
all day
that's it here you're getting bars that
are 15. one minute bar that's 15 points
already so you know when a Market's
moving very fast and when you have a lot
of volatility in the market
what is volatility it's just price
looking for areas that can for looking
for volume basically where it can
transact so
if
there's a lot of volatility you're gonna
get a lot of bars very quick you're
going to find yourself
late on trades you're going to have
signals by the time you act on it even
if you got a you know a VPN running it
automatically
you're not right next to the server okay
so you're going to get these bars where
you know you're trying to react you know
for example
you know look at this right you got how
many bars in
a couple of seconds right I mean forget
about you know what happened on
this is what yes but you know this is
Wednesday right you can see right 14 10
and two seconds three seconds eight
seconds it's Marcus just dropped very
fast for me personally I just found
using a Time based chart is is something
that's going to
help me manage my trades better right
because I put more of a Time component
into it than
you know sharp moves right and again you
know if I was using a I don't know if I
was using a
range-based chart
you know you could really ramp up some
of the stuff
you know quite High I don't know what
it's going to look like but
I I don't use range based charts anymore
uh
Lakeisha yes it will be recorded
well Amy that's
there's a there's signals right that's
why you know different markets trade
have different volatility so you got to
adjust it
um
and then that you can't use the same
signals the same setting on every Market
okay because
you know a an eight based
an eight tick
sorry an eight range chart on e-minis
it's going to trade a lot different than
say an eight range chart on
obviously bonds or it's going to trade
much differently than an a range chart
on gold or or wheat things like that so
you got to take that into account
um Bala
yeah you can actually all you got to do
is just reinstall it on your new pc
um
yeah Dave I'm getting to that uh in a
second here
okay guys
um well anyway while this when this card
comes up then I'll get into the
running markers
where am I here
with price scalper
so you're just waiting for that chart to
come up
um
yeah you know I don't use
Bloodhound so I don't know if it'll work
on blonde down I know it works on
markers so to set it up on markers
pretty simple it's going to take you
through the steps in the user guide all
these steps are in the user guide
already so
what you got to do is you open a chart
Right add markers plus the force copy
copy turn chart Trader on
et cetera the simple stuff that you
should already know
I use marketers copy
to copy the long signals and short
signals generated so basically
I'll show you here let me get up the
chart
um
where's my chart
okay so again this is that uh
eight range charge here
but all right so let's go here
um
so under the indicator
okay so you're gonna add copy copy the
force and this one I've got a
w
M A on weighted moving average 14 period
so again what you got to do
oh this one actually I am using fast
signals on you make sure you have the
data Series right so you'd have to go in
choose price scalper from here make sure
it appears you got to enable your
license whatever
filter you're using
on your
chart make sure you have it same set for
buy and sell this is three for the buy
the music I have this one is a three for
cell as well
okay
um change calculate on each tick so
again I have this one fast signal turned
on for shorts
this one is fast signal for Longs under
markers the force
actually I have it turned off why did I
do that yeah so it doesn't matter if you
have it checked or not what this is
looking for is looking at the copies the
triangles upper triangle down what's
plotting on my screen here triangle up
triangle down
um so let's just apologize for that I
was just playing around with it earlier
trying to make some changes
um triangle up triangle Down The Long
color the signals there now I have the
filters turned on okay so what is
filtering is this one here right you see
which says filter
this is my WMA
and its condition
this is for markets trending up
again all this is explained in the user
guide Mark is trending down
okay
and again this is what's being copied
it's a 14 period
um
WMA right here
and this is just the testing one but you
can see here right Long's disabled
because the market is starting to Trend
down
if Shorts now says
we'll say shorts enabled because Mark is
trending down so for example let's just
uh let's just kill this connection real
quick
um
let's close down some of these the
charts
go back to my playback now
going back to
the settings again is very simple it
just takes literally if you're familiar
with markers it should be second nature
to you you should be able to do it in
about two or three minutes if you you're
not as familiar with markers
maybe it's going to take you
five seven minutes to do you know but
it's you know simple things right enable
logs enable shorts Etc
lungs
signals triangle up it's all you'll just
copy what's in on the screenshots here
that's all you have to do right
and just make sure you have
everything set right the input series is
set the same as the way you like to look
at it on your chart
okay and
you know you got to set one up
I mean if you use markers you know you
got to set one up for the buy you gotta
set one up for the cell
right because you got to look for buy
signals you gotta look for sell signals
right make sure you change where it says
plot there
to
buy for the buys sells for the cells
all right let's go back here what's this
here
um
okay
so again you know this is
in playback mode already so you can see
I've got the filter on
for
trades yes well speed I'm going at 15
here trying to speed it up a little bit
all right make sure you're
ATM is the same ATM as in here right
make sure it's on auto mode filter on so
you see it's only going to take
Longs if the market is trending up right
now the Market's trending down so it
says long disabled shorts now shorts are
disabled because the market is trending
up based off of this
um
WMA that I'm using
as a filter
um James asked earlier mentioned tick
replay if you again you know sort of
just recap if you're using
a
software that requires tick replay
then yeah you're going to enable tick
replay scalper doesn't require
tick replay to work so you see okay so
it got in right as this Market was
starting to Trend down right because I
have the filter turned on
it got me short
okay
again this is the strategy that I'm
using is eight tick stop
tick tick profit again it's up to you
you know I don't know what everybody
uses
um
you know during the day atex will stop
me out a lot but at night time in the
evening session
um it's
I'm comfortable with it you know
sometimes I actually prefer to trade in
the evening session because one I don't
get any distractions don't get the phone
ringing at two in the morning
unless it's like
something catastrophic's happening but
uh
you know I don't get kids running around
I don't get I don't get the same
distractions that you'd get during the
normal day
so again I'm in this trade already you
can see oh that was fast but um I'll
just stop it there
again I'm just you know that was a big
drop from 81 down to 69.
um but
now you see Long's disabled shorts
enabled okay because now the market is
trending down so it's going to take
those trades if there's short trades
but anyway Dave in the user guide It's
explained out there it's it's spelled
out just as you're seeing you know on
this
on this here right it's all in there
explained out
um I'll touch base with the
Pablo about
the difference between plus and the
force
um which one you should be using
if you could use the
less expensive version with this I'm not
sure
um because I got the force
but again if you're going to use the
trend filter right this is what you just
copy and paste this
right for longs
it's going to be greater than for shorts
it's going to be less than right
so basically meaning the current bar
price is less than the previous bar
for shorts or the current price of this
bar is higher than the previous price of
the previous bar
um you bought markers from Apex
investing
markers should come from the indicator
store Pablo I don't know what that one
is that maybe Pablo's got to deal with
them
if it's markers from
the indicator store
on the underline I'd reach out to Mark
Pablo let's go to uh
what's his website the indicator story
he's a nice guy he's very helpful so if
you reach out to them and explain it
then you know he'll
I'm sure he'll do his best to help you
out just uh realize he's in a different
country different time zones and all
that I mean sometimes I get revised from
him in the middle of the night
so just be aware of that so anyway
yes Apex markers work okay well Marty
asks there's your question there
um anyway guys it's two o'clock I don't
want to keep you guys on any uh longer
you know it's Friday so hopefully you
got something
um
useful out of today's
thing and again you know sort of the
last minute things you know Dave I think
I've done some videos on markers search
my YouTube channel
um
because Pablo and I just did one
recently so and I'll be honest Pablo's a
great guy he's very helpful but I do
know that some people sometimes you know
I don't have a problem with his accent I
know some people do
um it's hard to for him something
English is not his first language so
sometimes it's a little hard for him to
find the right word to explain it so you
know just be a little bit flexible and
and work with that but he's extremely
helpful he's a great guy
um he goes that extra
yard for you so to speak
um yeah you know it's probably something
Dave it's probably something really
simple
um send him a screenshot
you know of your settings you know
because there's times where I've said
you know when I was getting started with
markers it's like it wouldn't trade just
like that and he's like well it's
because you have this setting in
incorrect so the more information you
give them sometimes the easier it is
so anyway guys
um I'm not going to keep you guys any
longer
John Luke I don't recall getting your
email if you could send me an email I'll
be on the lookout for it
but if you're interested in price
scalpers that is you know after this
weekend I'm going to put it back in the
vaults because I got some other stuff
um coming out you know we got our new
order flows Trader 6 release coming out
soon
um so I'm getting ready for that you
know I got to get all the documentation
done and stuff like that so
um you know
Now's the Time guys so go to price
scalper.com and again any questions
anybody's got any emails they want to
get out you know shoot them out to me
all right so have a great weekend
everyone take care bye bye